[Music]
football season is upon us and
apparently that means it's time to talk
politics I really wish that we could
separate sports and politics or pretty
much everything in politics but somehow
politics has infected every facet of
American life inserting politics into
virtually everything we consume strikes
me as a really bad sign as to what
direction this country is heading this
isn't to deny the feelings of the
players who take the knee but it is to
acknowledge why people watch sports in
the first place
people turn to sports video games and
other entertainment to escape politics
and the cold hard realities of life now
it seems that everywhere you turn
politics has reared its ugly head if you
don't take a side and scream about it or
at least tweet about it then you'll be
tossed in as racist or as anti-american
depending on who's leveling the charge
when our momentary escapes from reality
like sports are taken away from us in
exchange for more political bickering we
should all take a step back and assess
what's really going on here all right so
let's start with Trump Trump kicked this
whole controversy off on Friday night at
a speech in Alabama where he said that
NFL owners should get rid of players who
don't stand for the national anthem he
said and I quote get that son of a [ __ ]
off the field right now he's fired he's
fired and quote now let me be a hundred
percent crystal clear here calling a
football player or any other citizen a
son of a [ __ ] under any circumstances
is not the type of language that I'd
like to hear from the highest office in
the land as a free speech supporter I do
have major concerns about the chill
factor around free speech when the
president makes comments like this
personally I'd much rather have a
president who could share his own
personal beliefs on the matter while
still affirming the right of every
citizen to protest while also
acknowledging that private companies
contend to their employees however they
see fit that's how this exchange is
supposed to work in a free society
the president can say whatever he wants
the football players can do whatever
they want the teams can respond as they
see fit and you the
viewer can use your voice to share your
feelings on all of it so again to be
clear here even if Trump isn't saying or
tweeting statements just as I'd like him
to he does have the exact same right to
free speech the rest of us have now if
he tried to instruct federal agencies to
punish players or football teams for
exercising their right to free speech we
would have an illegal act and most
likely an impeachable offense as far as
I can see he didn't do that though he
did intentionally inflame the situation
by getting as close to seeming to use
government authority to silence people
without quite doing so understanding
that Trump said something but didn't
sign an executive action on it is an
important distinction though because
words are not action even when those
words are uttered by the President of
the United States and it's worth
mentioning that these protests did start
under President Obama so while Trump has
added fuel to the fire the seeds of
these protests had already been planted
now on to the players it is 100 percent
within the players right to exercise
their free speech as they see fit
while I personally would never kneel
during the national anthem it is
completely within their right to do so
and for those of you who think that
kneeling during the national anthem is
on American or not the players right
imagine for a moment what kind of
country you'd be living in if people
couldn't protest peacefully you may
think that these players are misguided
or that they're mistaken but imagine the
society we'd be living in if the
government could force people to stand
for the national anthem what else could
the government force us to do against
our will once we've given it that much
power of course the players exercising
their right to free speech must
understand that their actions might have
consequences as well this is the
implicit exchange we all must make to
live in a truly free society NFL teams
confine or suspend players as they see
fit and nobody has the inherent right to
play in the NFL by the way nobody has an
inherent right to work at Google either
but I didn't see many of the people who
were standing up for the players now
also stand up for fired Google engineer
James d'amour when he voiced his opinion
on Google's diversity program
interestingly d'amour was
fired for doing exactly what the company
had asked him to do attend a diversity
course and then share his opinion on it
so to recap Trump can say what he wants
as long as he doesn't use his government
influence to silence people players can
do what they want knowing that there
could be repercussions and teams can
deal with the players however they see
fit all right so now on to you the
public if football fans don't want to
buy tickets or watch games because of
the protests well then at the end of the
day even the great American pastime of
football is just a business owners and
management have the right and actually
the duty to do what's best for their
business if nobody's buying tickets
watching the games on TV or buying
merchandise then there will be nobody to
see the protests in the first place this
is actually the beauty of capitalism
everyone from the President to the
owners to the players to the fans all
have the ability to exercise their
speech as they see fit and if their
speech isn't enough to make a dent in a
cause they believe in then they can
still support a cause or not with their
hard-earned dollars this is freedom
actually working right in front of our
eyes and virtually all of the media is
making it seem like this is the end of
civilization if you stand with Colin
Kaepernick and the other players then
feel free to boycott the NFL if you
don't like the American flag being
disrespected by the players then boycott
the NFL I'd rather just watch some
football or in my case basketball but
you have the capacity and actually the
right to do whatever you want to be very
clear again i 100% stand by these
players doing whatever they want to
protest or not if that's what their
conscience tells them to do I also stand
by their employers to do what they feel
is right for their business even if I
don't agree with it and I do not want
the government to pass any law which
would impede on the rights of the
players or any sports organization this
position doesn't deny anyone's
grievances or feelings it actually
maximizes personal responsibility which
is the cornerstone of a free society
like I said before while I'd love
politics out of sports
sports out of politics it now seems that
our president and our media isn't gonna
let that happen anytime soon I basically
never watch SportsCenter anymore because
it's an endless bladder of crime stories
and politics with some game highlights
tossed in for good measure but those of
us who want to respect our fellow
citizens and the law can do is to
discuss the situation within the
framework of what it truly means to be
free nobody has been fired because of
their speech although Kaepernick does
remain a free agent which goes back to
that consequences thing no law has been
passed to actually silence anyone and we
all have an equal chance to have our
opinion heard while many would point
only to the evils of our political
system this story is actually showing
the strength of our democracy don't like
Trump statements don't vote for him
don't like the players who sat for the
anthem don't buy their jersey sick of
the whole damn thing find something
better to do than drink beer and watch
football on a Sunday all of the
discussion and debate around kneeling
for the anthem and honoring the country
is healthy as long as it doesn't turn
into violence and tyranny kamar heads
can win this game as long as we stand
for the principles of free speech and
the right to a peaceful protest even
when we don't want to the second we set
aside our principles we're just picking
a political team and rooting for our
side as if it were a football game for
now though I'll pass on picking a team
and remain a free agent in the
marketplace of ideas
[Music]
you
[Music]